it's the start of something new Vanessa
Hudgens and Major League Baseball's Cole
Tucker are engaged dreams give
me stuff yeah the athlete pop a question
after over two years together it's great
he's amazing the two started dating back
in 2020 after meeting in a not so
typical way me and Cole met on a zoom
meditation group very random yes Zoom
you gotta love it and since the pair has
been Inseparable it's just easy uh we're
like the same person
very much the same person but with
different interests so it's cool they
made their public debut at Vanessa's
Tick Tick boom AFI Fest Premiere in 2021
and then Rock the carpet together again
at the SAG Awards a year later he's just
kind of perfect for me yeah yeah and
Cole's not the only one showing up for
his boo we're just like the same we're
very similar we're very similar
Vanessa's been spotted at a few of his
baseball games over the years yeah it's
great I mean it's really cute because I
I during his season I've I've come to a
lot of games way more than I have in my
entire life condensed into a year
um and and it's so fun like I love going
and supporting and cheering him on but
for the premiere days he's like it's
game day babe he's like it's so nice I
get to come to your game and I'm like
it's
yes
same thing
um but it's great he's amazing yep and
the couple showing their love all over
social media
[Music]
we're such weirdos it's wonderful check
out Vanessa all smiles with Cole the
caption quote I'll stop the world and
melt with you I'm so so grateful I think
that it's also so important to stay
grateful for everything that you have in
life
um and I've been making that a priority
and I feel like it's just been making
magic happen all the more congrats to
the lovebirds
foreign
[Music]